ARE MOVING INTO RESTRICTIVE
TERRITORY.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WERE SEEING IN
FINANCIAL MARKETS.
WE ARE NOW ENTERING THIS MORE
RESTRICTIVE PHASE OF MONETARY
POLICY, SOMETHING WE HAVE NOT
SEEN FOR A WHILE, FOR SURE.
>> DEFINITELY TRUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>>> THIS IS KIND OF EXCITING.
TODAY MARKS THE FIRST DAY OF
JAPAN FULLY OPENING ITS BORDERS
AND ENDING ITS COVID-19 TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS.
JAPAN ALSO LIFTED A LIMIT ON
THE NUMBER OF ARRIVALS.
THE COUNTRY WILL NO LONGER
REQUIRE TAURUS TO BE PART OF A
TOUR GROUP.
LET'S BRING IN OUR SENIOR
TRAVEL ADVISOR, PETER
GREENBERG, TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS SO TIMELY.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT MY
FAMILY, MAYBE THIS YEAR JAPAN
WOULD BE ARE BIG TRIP.  EVERY
YEAR WE DO ONE BIG TRIP AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE ONCE
AGAIN.
NOW THAT JAPAN IS OPEN FOR
TOURISTS, ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET INTO THE
COUNTRY?
>> Reporter: FOR OVER TWO
YEARS, IT HAS BEEN SLOW GOING
OR NO GOING TO JAPAN, THEY WERE
TRULY A PANDEMIC ISOLATED
COUNTRY.
THEY STARTED TO OPEN THE DOORS
AND SAY YOU COULD GO WITH YOU
WERE PART OF RAIN ORGANIZED OR
GUIDED TOUR GROUP.
AS OF TODAY, ANYBODY CAN COME,
YOU JUST NEED PROOF OF
VACCINATION OR NEGATIVE PCR
TEST.
OTHER THAN THAT, IT IS OPEN.
WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT THAT
IS THE NUMBERS BETWEEN THE
EGINNING OF THIS YEAR AND NOW,
ONLY ABOUT 500,000 PEOPLE HAVE
VISITED JAPAN SINCE JUNE,
COMPARED TO 32 MILLION THAT
WENT IN 2019.
THAT COULD GIVE YOU A BIG IDEA
OF WHY THIS IS A BIG DEAL FOR
JAPAN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WHAT IS THE BEST TIME TO FLY TO
JAPAN AND WHAT FACTORS SHOULD
WE BE CONSIDERING?
>> IT WOULD BE NOW BECAUSE
THERE IS NOBODY THERE.
THE QUALIFICATION IS THIS,
THERE HAVE BEEN THE SAME ISSUES
WITH SUPPLY CHAIN PROBLEMS AND
STAFF SHORTAGES THAT WE HAVE.
70% OF THEM ARE REPORTING STAFF
SHORTAGES, KEEP THAT IN MIND.
YOU WILL NEED TO WEAR A MASK ON
MANY JAPANESE AIRLINES AND IN
PUBLIC PLACES ROUTE THE
COUNTRY.
OTHER THAN THAT, THE YEN IS
THAT A 25 YEAR LOW AGAINST THE
DOLLAR THAT, MUCH LIKE AGAINST
THE BRITISH POUND OR THE EURO,
IT IS A GOOD DEAL WHEN YOU GET
THERE.
>> JAPAN IS A PRETTY EXPENSIVE
TRIP. FOR THOSE TRAVELING TO
JAPAN SPECIFICALLY, WHAT
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE?
>> THERE ARE NEW INSURANCE
PRODUCTS TO PROTECT YOU AND
COVER YOU IF YOU TEST POSITIVE
FOR COVID.
OTHER THAN THAT, HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH A TRIP